What would kidney tonic general on the rife be used for?
It's interesting. Two kidney questions. There are two different people that ask this question.
So on the rife machine, there are several kidney programs.
And the kidney tonic general is just a general healing for the kidneys.
So there are just known frequencies that are for the kidney itself.
And remember, I said, the best use of the rife is to kill pathogens or kill cancer cells.
But also it can bring back general tone to cells.
So there's known frequencies for the kidney and sometimes, okay, so one theory of ill health is that.
Let's say you're, if my kidney stay with kidney, my kidneys are not functioning well.
They're, they're vibrating at a different frequency, whether in a health.
So if you can hit them at their own frequency at the normal kidney frequency,
could you bring back normal cell residents and help bring back normal health?
That's part of the idea of frequency technology.
So some of the, like the normal, normalization program.
So they're named different things partly depending upon my mood when I was naming them.
So the kidney tonic general is just a general frequency,
different general frequencies for the kidneys to bring them back to tone.
So well, what if I have kidney stones, is that a good one to run?
Oh, yeah, it can be, but it's probably not going to help with it.
I think there's a kidney stone frequency.
So run that or stones frequency run that probably more so.
So kidney tonic general would be if there's a kidney stones per se isn't really an inherent issue with the kidneys.
Meaning that there's no dysfunction of the kidneys.
Therefore you form stones.
Stones are formed because of excess oxalates.
And sometimes are inability to remove oxalates from our gut.
So that could have to do with genetic variance.
It could have to do with dietary things.
And it's not a dysfunction of the kidneys.
Therefore, you form stones.
So if I had kidney stones, I wouldn't necessarily run that program except that.
If I have kidney stones for a long period of time, it can cause dysfunction in the kidneys.
So therefore I'm trying to keep my kidneys healthy too.
So therefore I think it can be beneficial to run that program.
But it's not going to help remove kidney stones per se.
Hopefully that helps.
Let's say I have cancer in the liver to run the liver programs with that be good.
Yeah, it would be good because the cancer in the liver is causing dysfunction in the liver.
But I have to run the liver cancer programs.
Or whatever cancer is metastasized liver.
Let's say it's breast cancer metastasized liver.
I'd be running the breast cancer programs to help kill the cancer in the liver.
But the breast cancer metastasized liver probably causing liver dysfunction.
So it might be good to run the liver program as well.
But I am actually put the liver program in just in everybody's program because you want it helps with detoxification pieces too.
But that was just an example.